[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thanks for coming everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
very very warm welcome for you to Lisbon
we are delighted to have you here I want
to say in the name of all the city that
is a privilege to have you here and
wealth between us what has been one of
the most remarkable voices fighting for
all of us the most decisive battle that
we face together the fight against
climate change
welcome second word that I want to say
is that that we are really aware in in
this one that globally we are losing the
battle against climate change so when I
hear some voices that are concerned
about the loudness of your voice when I
hear voice is the saying there is too
many demonstrations about climate change
I want to say precisely the message
released on this precise of the opposite
we need a stronger voice from you with
an a stronger voice from you we need a
stronger voice because we need to work
more together to win this battle we are
not winning this battle and we need to
do more globally to win this battle the
third message that I want to give you
very simple is that in Lisbon you are
going to look at some new very good
friends but most of all I want that when
you leave this one you find a community
that's really engaged in concrete action
to fight climate change Portugal and
Lisbon we are now declining on emissions
but we have the conscience that we need
to do much more much faster with
concrete and decisive actions to do we
have this community this amazing number
of activists
and we are fully committed to this
strategy of doing our part to reduce
emissions and doing our part in fighting
global change so Greta I want to when
you live this one that you feel that we
hear a strong committed community and
basically that every time that you think
about Lisbon you think also about your
home thank you very much my name is
representation of rise for future in
virtual grammatically first of all would
like to first of all would like to give
a warm welcome to Reza and their group
and we hope you enjoy Lisbon and your
dogs
and we are youth movement that fights
for climate justice we fight for climate
justice because our house is on fire and
because our house is on fire
we've organized and strike for the
climate together with thousands of
students many times this year our
demands are simple in Portugal we need
to reach carbon neutrality by 2030 we
need to keep fossil fuels including gas
on the ground we need to provide clean
energy for all and we need to cancel new
airport projects Monte to include we
need a system change not a climate
change we are still far from winning we
know that change disturbs the ones in
power they tell us our country's
ambitions in climate policies but we
know it isn't they tell us they are
doing what they can but we know they're
not but we also know that's it this is
the struggle of our generation and we
will not give up we all have raised like
a wave to demand climate justice for all
and we need everyone to join us if we
lose everybody loses now we are like
grete heading to cop 25 in my dream will
meet with thousands of all the climate
activists from many countries including
the global south
there will be protesting once again
against the priority given to profit
over our lives
the seas are rising and so are we
Greta thank you for helping inspire the
youth thank you for being radical in
your speech thank you for showing
politicians and corporations that will
no more accept the climate chaos they
provoked great time don't stop cuz
together we are going to change the
system in the men's climate justice for
all
we are the ones we have been waiting for
and we'll put out the fire in our house
thank you in spoken now we have a brief
remark because social justice is climate
justice we have a brief remark from a
bell who reeks from so many because I'm
from Amazon rainforest and basically I
want to say that the world needs to know
that every forest is being pillaged by
corporations by uses corporations and I
have to say to the words that the people
from Amazon rainforest are being killed
every day in the world needs to know
this I want to savor thankful to Greta
to be the biggest and most active voice
in this battle and I want to ask for all
of you we need to save Amazon rainforest
please
[Applause]
now we have some brief remarks from
Riley hwhiteland both skipper I just
like to say a few comments about the
trip um it's not really recommended to
cross the North Atlantic this time of
year and it was quite an eventful trip I
think we managed to dodge 60 knots and
seven meter waves twice we had a huge
wave come over the top and rip a chair
off the deck we snapped a few ropes that
were very important yeah a lot of stuff
happened it feels like we sort of
crammed about three years worth of
experience into three weeks it was a
very difficult trip I'd like to thank
Nicky Henderson she was absolutely
amazing
made the trick a lot less stressful for
me she's sort of like having probably
three crew members on board
she was really wonderful I'm also Elena
who he arguably had the most difficult
job on board she was looking after baby
boy Lenny who's he turns one in three
days time it was very brave of Greta and
Sante to embark on such a journey and
speaking about those experiences it was
really good to see her and her father be
able to get to enjoy so much time on the
water and I think that I think that it's
a trip that they'll be talking about
amongst each other and with their family
and friends for many years to come so
I'm very proud to have been a small part
in greatest journey
now we have a brief remark from Nikki
Anderson professional sailor and from
bud screw thank you thank you for coming
as a professional sailor I think we are
very used to going to sea and dealing
with what nature throws at us as as
Riley said it wasn't that easy and so
for me this trip wasn't so
nerve-wracking but I can imagine for
Greta and for some of the crew for her
father for everyone this was a big deal
to embark on this so for me I was
talking with Brenda's father about the
fact that going to see changes you and
we were talking about how it changes us
and because for me I go to see all the
time I thought what is this what is this
trip about how do I feel differently and
with very very little time to speak to
you I suppose I wanted to reach out to
the maybe the people who aren't him
before I came on this trip I admit that
I was quite nervous to admit that there
was a problem in the world
I was quite intimidated by the
negativity and being around these people
being around Greta for 21 days has made
me feel like together like you're part
of something and it makes it much less
scary and it also gives you hope and so
I hope
[Music]
I hope that we all in whatever way we
can
whether it's sailing across an Atlantic
looking after your child traveling
around America researching however you
want to do it I hope that by working
together we can do it in a much easier
and better way thank you everyone so
much for coming here and for welcoming
us that feels very it feels very good
doesn't it to be welcomed in such such a
way so thank you so much and of course
thank you to Elena riding many and Enki
for making this possible and I owe you
so much and thank you and and thank you
everyone else who has been helping us
for making this possible and I it feels
I'm so grateful for for having for
having done this trip and for having
this experience it's and I'm so honored
to be here in beautiful Lisbon and
Portugal and
thank you so much for having us here and
and also after a trip like this for
being isolated three weeks being in such
a limited space with such limited things
to do you get very relaxed in a way you
are disconnected from everything and
everyone basically and and for we're
coming into land it is so overwhelming
so I think we have all of us are still a
bit overwhelmed so you will have to bear
with us and especially having all these
people greeting you it is it feels
amazing but our brains are not used to
it yet it feels so amazing to be to be
home back in Europe I have been on on a
quite an adventure and we've all been on
quite an adventure and it feels good to
be back and of course I as well as the
other climate activists we will not stop
we will continue to do to do whatever we
can
[Applause]
[Music]
continue to travel around and to put
pressure and on people in power and to
make sure that they put their prioritize
that they prioritize this highest and
and then we eventually we will be going
to cop 25 in Madrid and we will will we
continue the fight there to make sure
that within those walls the voices of
the people are being heard and that the
voices of the future generations are
being heard and that the voices from the
people especially from the global South
are being heard I don't have I don't
have much to say just that we are facing
a global emergency and we need to we
need to see it from a holistic point of
view and we need to do everything we can
we need to work together to make sure
that we secure future living conditions
humankind and that we fight for not only
ourselves but for our children and for
our grandchildren and for every single
living being on earth and everyone has
to do everything they can in order to
make sure they are on the right side of
history because in order to change
everything we need everyone and I hope
every one of you will get active and and
start fighting for your future as well
and once again thank you to to these
people to Riley
Lenny Elena and Nikki or for doing this
this trip has been this trip has been
great
actually I think we needed some some
relaxing time all of us especially me is
some time to sort of think everything
through and to relax and how I feel I
feel good I feel like I want to continue
now I feel energized
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so if I'm right the question was if I
have any plan to present to politicians
what we what we young people are doing
right now is to what we are demanding is
that but we are demanding is that
especially the people in power should
listen to the science they should not I
mean of course they should listen to us
children as well but we are not the
experts of the scientists are the ones
that needs to be heard and the experts
and so so what we are saying is for them
to to unite behind the science to listen
to the science it should not be up to us
children teenagers to 2% plants in order
to to secure future living conditions so
so yeah if I got seasick I got seasick
the first day only the first day okay I
mean a bit but yeah I got a bit seasick
but then the rest of the trip nothing so
I mean so yeah I was very lucky
incredibly lucky and I don't think not
many of us we didn't suffer from
seasickness on the boats I think at all
so we are very grateful for that
we are in Chile
we are the only country that we have the
private water that's really awful
dangerous for us the President of Chile
is the owner of the water the government
is the owner of the water and the
ministers the big part of the greatest
part of the water incident
it's not a question but the people need
to know to know these people people know
too
she is the only country with the created
world
[Applause]
hello Katrina here from RTP one of the
big headlines here is that we are about
to build a new airport in Montego so we
have three main airports in Portugal
what do you think about that that we are
about to build anywhere works
I don't know the full background of this
but I mean when we are thinking of doing
planning such things in the future we
need to to put this in a bigger
perspective and to to really look at it
how will this benefit us and is this
really will this do more good than harm
you
we cannot only think about today and
what we want today and what benefits us
today but also in the future Greta Greta
here good morning from miss fame and you
said you hold my thank you so much from
mediaset Spain quaterly a show welcome
here
we know you browses a lot of good
emotions in everyone you movement your
message look around hundreds of people
activists journalists many of us have
got here by playing as you can imagine I
came I come from Madrid so the question
is for those who can't afford traveling
by a sailing boat what cheap options
would you recommend us to take
I mean the we are not doing this trip
and I'm not traveling like this because
I want everyone to do so I'm doing this
to sort of send a message that it is
possible that it is impossible to live
sustainable today and that needs to
change it needs to become much easier
and I mean we can't require from
everyone to to rely on people like this
to sail you across an ocean that is
absurd but I mean I'm not telling I am
not telling anyone else how to travel or
not how not to travel but but of course
there are there are more sustainable
alternatives but I'm not telling anyone
else what to do so my question is do you
receive the letter of our environmental
Minister what you talked about the
proposals to the future about neutrality
about the carbonic and what do you think
about this about Portugal being the
first country to embrace that challenge
I'm not 100% sure I think we on the boat
received some kind of message it's very
hard to communicate so I'm not I can't
guarantee you that I've seen it but I
don't know I don't know the details if I
would comment it I would probably need
to read it once again but I think we can
safely say that no country in the world
is doing enough and that we that we all
need to do much more than we are doing
today
[Applause]
[Music]
I work for news magazine for kids and
young people so I have a question for
you about this topic people say that you
are an angry kids adults mainly what you
have to say to them
I think people are under estimating the
force of angry kids I mean we are angry
we are frustrated that it because that
is because of of a good reason if they
want us to stop being angry then maybe
they should stop making us angry
[Applause]
hi in Brazil president Bernardo recently
fires in the Amazon and sometimes
President Trump loves you on Twitter so
what do you say about politicians that
are trying to blame activists for
problems
I mean when people in power are
criticizing you like that that is only
proof that that you are having an impact
and that that you among others are
bringing change or trying to bring
change and many people don't want that
and of course they will do everything
they can to try to prevent change from
happening but we will continue to make
change happen and we will make sure they
will have to change hi my name is
Ukraine from Reuters and what is the
main thing you want to see coming out of
cop 25 in Madrid and where are you going
to go next what's the next step for you
what I want to come up from the cops 25
is as for every other such meeting that
world leaders finally understands the
urgency and that they listen to the
science and act on the science that they
start treating this crisis like a crisis
and cooperates internationally and many
people say that it doesn't matter
nothing will come out become 25 as all
all the previous meetings and that that
maybe and we probably already know the
outcome but that can never be a reason
to not try to do everything you can to
make sure that this outcome and the next
steps for me is right now I will stay in
Lisbon a few days and try to just sort
everything else I haven't been following
the the news I have been living under a
rock for the few weeks so I need to know
what's what's happened and also to get
everything organized to make sure that I
have everything I need and and and then
when I feel like it go go to Madrid and
for the for the March on Friday
[Applause]
and then I don't know I will have to
make to create a schedule for the clock
25 as I haven't been able to do so
during the trip and so so now I will
have to choose which events I want to
participate in and what I want to do and
also talk with with other activists
local activists what what we what we
will do and after Madrid I'm going home
for Christmas so the press the press
conference is closed
[Applause]
[Music]